go to our top story here at 4 o'clock
we're talking about expanded vaccine
eligibility now of course we've been
telling you about this for a while now
and
today is the day that everybody 16 and
older can now get the co-ed vaccine here
in nevada
i felt safe throughout the whole process
and feeling good right now
we also hit a major milestone here in
clark county more than a million doses
now given out
let's head outside to sally jaramillo
live from unlv and sally a lot of
younger people
finally getting their turn today
yeah christian and david it was a very
busy day here at unlv
and just to give you some perspective
the lines really started from here
and it went all around the entire
building
as you can see now the lines did move
quickly and we have no lines right now
so michael gardner is the ceo and
president for the unlv school of
medicine he says
it's terrific that they finally opened
up to the public and no longer do
they have to ask the person's occupation
2200 people were scheduled for today
sierra bone is a 19 year 19 years old
she got her first dose
she tells me she's looking forward to
hanging out with family and friends
again
i think it's important to get it because
like you can hang out
you know hurt immunity i would say to
just try and get
try and get it as soon as you can
this location here at unlv will close in
an hour they do have spots open for the
rest of the week
a reminder also the las vegas convention
center as well as cashman center resume
vaccines as early as tomorrow so
if you want to make an appointment make
sure you head over to our website
eightnewsnow.com reporting live
sally jaramillo 8 news now